this week in Bitcoin was absolutely wild
it's like just kidding actually it's
super super boring it's a bear market
and so things just kind of go sideways
but there's two main stories that I
would pay attention to the first is the
Federal Reserve the Federal Reserve
increased interest rates by 75 basis
points closing in on four percent but
what does that exactly mean for Bitcoin
as we have seen since November of last
year the FED first talked tough and now
they're acting tough continuing to
create tighter Financial conditions
which brings down asset prices and we've
seen stocks fall 20 to 30 percent and
Bitcoin is full 70 or more now we're
just going sideways and it looks like no
matter how much pain the FED brings
Bitcoin is being resilient that doesn't
mean it can't go down more doesn't mean
that it'll recover it just means that
it's quite interesting to see the FED
continued to create Tighter and Tighter
Financial conditions and Bitcoin is
weathering the storm now of course that
leads to the second thing which is Wall
Street firms they really are coming all
of a sudden it looks like the Wall
Street firms are showing up for
Fidelity's talking about no fee crypto
trading and on top of that we also see
people like JP Morgan coming in and
doing defy trades the hell is going on
everyone for years has been saying
institutions are coming well now it
appears that they actually are here
whether it's the FED punishing the
market or it's the Big Wall Street firm
starting to actually dip their toe and
get involved in the Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency Industry you should be
paying attention because during bear
markets that's when the real gets
built that's right I just cursed you
know it's serious as we watch the bear
Market play out I continue to see great
Founders leaving all sorts of big tech
companies or large Financial firms to
start new companies I see the companies
that were already started acquiring new
talent that is quite impressive
ultimately bear markets are for building
Bitcoins going sideways you're getting
lulled to sleep but don't go to sleep
make sure you continue to pay attention
don't forget that these are brought to
you every single Saturday by FTX FTX as
much as 85 percent cheaper than their
competitors and they've also introduced
digital stock trading with no payment
for order flow and no transaction fees
go check them out by clicking on the
link in the description and I'll see you
all next Saturday